bronze silber gold ja diese
schwimmabzeichen haben viele von uns in
jungen jahren bereits gemacht doch das
erste abzeichen ist das seepferdchen
ja es gibt aber immer noch viel zu viele
menschen die gar nicht schwimmen können
und das sind nicht nur kinder auch viele
erwachsene können nicht schwimmen
darunter auch der cdu-politiker hauke
göttsch er ist 55 jahre alt und lernte
jetzt erst schwimmen auf dem weg zum
seepferdchen sozusagen wir haben ihn mit
der kamera beim schwimmunterricht
begleitet ein kurzer check der
wassertemperatur
ein prüfender blick acht uhr morgens 12
grad außentemperatur cdu-politiker hauke
göttsch ist hochmotiviert endlich
schwimmen zu lernen ich kenne nicht als
landtagsabgeordnete mich irgendwo
hinstellen und und die großen reden
halten und sagen hier ihr müsst das
schwimmen lernen das ist sogar wichtig
und da habt ihr auch spaß aber das ist
auch lebensnotwendig schwimmen 55 jahre
alt ist der schleswig holsteinische
landtagsabgeordnete jetzt trainiert er
endlich für seepferdchen er will vor
allem anderen erwachsenen die nicht
schwimmen können mut machen
ich habe schon sehr viel feedback
bekommt wie viele erwachsene nicht
schwimmen kann
es ist natürlich eine hemmschwelle das
machen heranzugehen man muss sich die
zeit nehmen und dann kümmern uns einfach
also einfach mal machen aber nicht
schwimmen zu können ist oft ein
tabuthema bei schwimm der rache von
götze die nachfrage hier tatsächlich
noch nicht so gut war
und wenn die nachfrage da ist
tatsächlich keine eschen zum kurs weil
doppel respekt da ist macht mich doch
nicht hin und also der erste der
wirkliche aufgestockt bis zum 5 los
gegen das schwimmunterricht für hauke
göttsch mit zwei schwimmnudeln und einem
brett auch wenn der 55-jährige gute
fortschritte macht noch ist luft nach
oben
jetzt zehn stunde sehe ich auch einige
fortschritte obwohl ich gedacht hätte
dass ich eigentlich so etwas der dritten
stunde schon die bruder filmen aber das
ist nicht so es ist als erwachsener hat
man ja doch inzwischen gesperrt weil man
nicht dran geglaubt dass das wasser ein
trick auch lötzsch hat es gewagt endlich
schwimmen zu lernen und das rettende
ufer sollte nach ein paar weiteren
unterrichtsstunden auch bald in
reichweite sein